son nom lui ouvre bien des portes est au
big up le coeur de la formation
renata faut aider la veuve de l'ex maire
de toronto
la belle soeur du premier ministre
provincial et la tante du conseiller
municipal local tosques daverat et a
noté jean ici en anglais et en polonais
elle vante les réalisations politiques
de sa famille
les fall seront toujours numéro 1 pour
cet homme
il explique qu'il a chez lui une photo
prise avec dame fall sirena trafford
pour continuer le travail de son défunt
mari elle sera bonne ajoute celui ci
elle dit s'être lancé en politique pour
eux pour aider les électeurs qui peinent
à joindre les deux bouts et oublient qu
on aura beau être le coeur de la fournée
chine c'est aussi paradoxalement un
château fort libéral fédéral la ministre
sortante des sciences et des sports
kirsty dans qu'une représente la
circonscription depuis onze ans à la
dernière élection elle a récolté 62 %
des voix loin devant son adversaire
conservateur
la candidate vedette découvre que le nom
fort de risque de ne pas être suffisant
pour se faire élire des électeurs
refusent qu'elle installe ses pancartes
sur leur terrain certes elle a confronté
sur les positions anti-immigration et
climato sceptiques ne sont pas pour
d'autres
les déboires de renata faut de la
rattrape elle poursuit son beau frère
dogues en lien avec la succession de rob
ford
renata ford a aussi été arrêté pour
conduite avec facultés affaiblies et
cette dame trouve sa candidature bien
étranges ou d'identité
malgré cet accueil tiède renata ford
reste confiante et elle poursuit sa
modeste campagne ici philippe leblanc
radio canada toronto